I was the CEO of a large religious
nonprofit spoke at some of the largest
churches in America was on television in
70 different markets but more than
anything else I just wanted to be a good
parent I told all three of my children
when the going gets tough you have to
choose the road less traveled the narrow
path I had no idea how difficult that
was going to become I knew from the time
I was three or four years of age that I
was transgender I knew if I came out I
would lose everything but the call
toward authenticity is sacred and for
the greater good and it asks you to
trust that the truth not only sets you
free it will set everyone free I decided
to stake my life on it so I came out
turns out if you spend most of your life
working in the conservative religious
worlds coming out as transgender is not
all that great for your career
[Laughter]
within seven days I lost every single
one of my jobs my family was supportive
but struggling most of my friends and
co-workers had rejected me the rest were
confused one friend said you really
messed with me I said yeah well get in
line said you were my only example of an
alpha male who was gentle and I thought
oh you're right I was an alpha male and
I was gentle and if it was hard for him
how much more difficult was it for my
own son estrangement was not an option
who was Father's Day and my girls
brought me craft beer and a homemade jar
of pickles which in my estimation is the
perfect Father's Day gift but the
question remained did I call my own
father to calm and I continue down this
spiral of denial pretending that my dad
was still well my dad to not call was to
acknowledge that everything had changed
it meant that I was in four years of
pain and mourning and sadness but
ultimately hope for reconciliation
there's no playbook and once father of
30 plus years decides to transition to
the female gender but my dad did teach
me one thing he said the road to
redemption always comes from choosing
the narrow path and so I decided not to
call that day and a few months later
Paula flew out and met me at a hotel in
New York my wife and I I knocked on the
door and this woman answered it
definitely wasn't my dad it's good to
see you she said didn't sound like my
dad either we went to lunch and the
waiter came to take our order he said
let's start with the ladies but there
was only one lady at the table and it
was my wife and oh my god there are two
women at the table and my dad ordered
something like lettuce and I was like I
have fries on my plate did my dad liked
fries I don't remember I think he liked
him but she wasn't eating them here's
this woman who knew everything about me
and I knew nothing about her I don't
even remember saying goodbye all I could
think about that day is it was late
September in New York and I was wearing
white jeans you don't wear white after
Labor Day in New York there was a knock
at the door and all I could think about
was here I stand in my wrong jeans and
then I saw these big blue eyes I loved
so much and they were staring back at me
and disbelief and I thought oh this is
not going to be easy when one person in
the family transitions the entire family
transitions whether they want to or not
now for those in the fringes it was easy
the liberal said Oh wonderful she's
found her truth how delightful and the
Conservatives said yeah that's messed up
I'm out of here but for my family
neither extreme was going to work their
anger their hurt their love and loyalty
all of it had to be brought on to the
road of trials was it all a lie
every game of catch in the front yard
the Mets season tickets was that with my
dad or was that with her I remember this
one time my dad took me on a bike ride
through Heckscher Park to teach me about
sex he explained the parts of the body
that I now know he wished he weren't
hers had my father ever even existed
now grief grief is without rules grief
borrows your car without asking wrecks
it and then doesn't apologize and I was
a wreck this was heavy I retreated into
myself I was angry I felt betrayed I
guess I should have known by the fact
that you encouraged me to be a Mets fan
that you were preparing me for life's
really big disappointments yeah yeah
that's true pen yet yet there were the
games of catch and there were the season
tickets and bacon egg and cheese
sandwiches every Saturday from the best
bagel place on Long Island my father
lived this life he didn't want to live
but he lived it so that I could have a
dad I stopped
wondering if my dad had ever existed he
had existed willfully consciously
intentionally each and every day of my
growing up for that I was thankful
paula's body was hers now and her
transformation was complete but my
transformation was just beginning I had
another trial another journey another
choice to heed my father's advice and
continue down that narrow path so most
days I believe there is a God
Tuesdays and Thursdays can be tough and
any day that you're on the New Jersey
Turnpike I mean really you know it's
hard to believe in God when your soul is
in the wrong body still somehow I ended
up in ministry when I lost all my jobs
it was nothing personal it's what
religious tribes do they believe in the
enemy is necessary for the tribe to
survive so where no enemy exists they
create one right now sexual minorities
are the enemy my departure was Swift and
sure I was surprised when my son left
his job teaching in West Philadelphia to
go into the ministry I did not see that
one coming and now I wondered what would
he do I didn't have to wait that long to
find an answer six months after that
first visit he invited me back to New
York the designers at the Brooklyn
Bridge they had their share of bad luck
John Roebling he died shortly after the
bridges construction began his son
Washington took over but he suffered
from decompression sickness his wife
Emily became the surrogate executive
engineer who oversaw the bridges
completion father and son John and
Washington done in by their work was
this sunny day in May and my father and
I sat in the shadow of that Brooklyn
Bridge but our lives follow the
roebling's father and son son in by our
work my father thought that her friends
in church would would carry her through
her transition and they did not they
ditched her and they clung to me I was
the pastor of a new church in Brooklyn
this wonderful group of forward-thinking
people and yet we were
financially tied a really conservative
churches to hold space for Paula and
jeopardizing our own church's livelihood
I sort of straddled the line between
these warring worlds and so I said to my
dad I said dad you know I still live and
work in your old world is it is it
possible that you might extend an olive
branch for my sake and her response was
impassioned you said to me do you have
any idea what it feels like to finally
show yourself to your true friends and
have them completely reject you to ask
you to live a lie do you know what that
feels like and I didn't know what that
felt like but I knew I had a decision to
make
it was the decision to continue down
that narrow path through nights but for
the first time I caught a glimpse of
light could not ask my father to be
anything other than her true self
so as we sat by the river that day
Jonathan talked about his pain his
suffering is grief his confusion he
brought all of himself to that
conversation and it taught me to be the
cause of such pain but as he talked
there was something redemptive going on
full of tension but possibility grounded
in that narrow path he said this is
always going to be hard it always will
be but Dad I love you you know my son is
the best of me and more he's bold and
strong sensitive and thoughtful I guess
you could say he's an alpha male who's
gentle it was time for my daughters to
meet their but Paula we went back to my
apartment and my daughters were coloring
at the dining room table and there was
this awkward silence and finally my
youngest asked a single confident
question so grandpa do you have a penis
and after the tension abated and the
laughter subsided my girls took their
grandpa back into their room and showed
her their new toys and they christened
her with a new name they called her
grand Paula
so this past summer I had all five of my
granddaughters at my home there in the
foothills of the Rocky Mountains we went
swimming the cool waters of the river
that flows through our little town and
one day one of Jonathan's girls said to
me grim Paula
can we go tubing on the river and I said
well you know I'd really wait until your
daddy gets here for that that feels to
me like that ought to be his call and
she said oh but Grampa he'll exactly
make the same decision you would he's a
lot like you you know and I thought yeah
he is a lot like me both of us
determined to find the narrow path and
follow it through the long dark night
all the way to the light of dawn have
you ever noticed that a child who is
secured a child who knows love that that
child will dance
they've waved their arms they kicked
their legs to a music that only they can
hear it's it's the music of a child who
is safe and unharmed and wholly loved
the day after my children met their
grand Paula she took him to go get
donuts and I watched as they walked down
the street and my girls grabbed my
father's arms and they danced my
father's arms swung wildly he bought
them one too many doughnuts because you
always do and I watched my older
daughter take a bite of her doughnut and
she unleashed two jumps and a twirl it
was perfect that narrow path it always
has its share of burdens and challenges
but I was certain that we were going to
see this through to redemption I looked
at my dad and I looked at my girls who
were dancing and you know eating their
doughnuts and I said aloud to no one in
particular I said this this is how God
sees my dad my father was literally born
again and by choosing the narrow path of
redemption I was born again with her
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]